washington journal continues
fell sheenan is the author of a cruel
and shocking act the secret history of
the kennedy assassination and here to
talk about these pending release of
documents concerning jfk's assassination
good morning good morning what are we
expected to see released well we're
going to see thousands and thousands of
pages of documents released online it's
fascinating that people all around the
world are going to see these documents
at the same moment
and
it's going to be
very difficult for weeks if not months
to really understand what's in there
we understand that these include 3 100
documents about the assassination that
have never been seen by the public
before and something like 30 000 other
documents that have been released in the
past uh in redacted form with with
material edited to doubt we're supposed
to see them in full but we still have no
word from president trump about exactly
what he's going to allow to be released
is it your expectation that everything
comes out or because does he have the
ability to hold some back the only
person who has the power to withhold any
of these documents there's a 1992 law
that required the release of every
document in the government's files
relating to the assassination the only
person who can block that is the
president and it turns out the president
is donald trump right now he has said
that he will release all of these files
unless there is compelling national
security information that has to be
withheld and i think there's a frantic
effort at the white house this week by
the cia and the fbi in particular to try
to block some of this this release when
in your mind what would what would
classify as a national security concern
well to my mind i mean i i guess i speak
as an historian these days i think this
should all be released it should have
been released years ago you know we've
been dealing with conspiracy theories
now for 54 years it's really time to put
an end to this as best we can
but apparently the argument may be made
this week that some of these documents
were prepared in the 1990s
involve relatively recent intelligence
or law enforcement operations that might
still be
endangered if these documents were
released
the national archives holds these
there's a website that you can go to to
see the documents that already exist and
then the pending documents as they come
out why
does it take so long to get us to this
point with for the release of all this
information so many years later well
the story is that in 1991 oliver stone
produced his film jfk which produced a
million conspiracy theories about the
assassination really kicked up a ruckus
congress reacted the following year by
passing a law that required the release
of all documents related to the
assassination to try to tamp down some
of the conspiracy theories and as a
result of that law in the 1990s millions
of pages of documents were made public
now a small handful about 3 100
documents now have been held back all
these years because agencies like the
fbi and the cia argued that they might
somehow endanger national security but
under that law there was a 25-year
deadline and that 25-year deadline to
release everything in full is is
thursday afo sheena the author of a
cruel and shocking act the secret
history of the kennedy assassination
here to talk about the release of these
documents if you want to ask them
questions 202 748-8001 for republicans
202 748 000 for democrats and
independence 202-7 freight 8002. what
would you like information would you
like to see come up from these documents
are there still unanswered questions in
your mind about what happened there are
uh the thing the material i'm most
interested in uh involves what i've
always considered the the secret hidden
chapter of the kennedy assassination
story which is uh it involves mexico
city it involves a mysterious trip that
lee harvey oswald the assassin paid to
mexico just several weeks before the
assassination where we know from
previously declassified files he met
with cuban spies and russian spies and
other people who at the very height of
the cold war might have wanted to see
president kennedy dead and we know two
other things one is that oswald wasn't
about marxist he was a supporter of
castro's revolution
and the fact that the cia had oswald
under aggressive surveillance in mexico
city while he was there
in mexico city he apparently was talking
openly about his intention to kill the
president the question in my mind is
what did the cia know in real time weeks
before the assassination about the
threat that this man posed does it
change the he acted alone narrative then
it might it doesn't point to something
like a second gunman in dealey plaza but
it certainly suggests he may have been
in contact with people
who may have encouraged him to do this
maybe even offered to help him to do
this or to help after he was able to
carry it out and that is uh you know
that leads to the question of whether or
not there were accessories to this crime
whether or not there were
co-conspirators in this crime so when
it's released and people go to the
website is this
material that the average person could
understand or do you have to have some
working knowledge of how this works to
kind of even make sense of what's
released no and that's why i fear a lot
of people are going to be disappointed
when they begin to pour through this
material
you know this is this is government
officials writing to other government
officials a lot of this is cia code
names and pseudonyms some of it's going
to be in foreign languages some of it
based on past experience is going to be
illegible i think it's going to be very
hard even for people who have some
background on this to make sense of
these documents for for say weeks or
months or even years is it a possibility
that the documents can reveal how both
the cia and the fbi performed in this
matter when it comes to the lead up to
the assassination and how they reacted
afterward absolutely and i say i think
you know the narrative of the kennedy
assassination has changed dramatically
over the years from the idea that oswald
was this pure lone wolf this delusional
young man whose plot to kill kennedy
could never have been foiled certainly
the fbi and the cia argued they didn't
have the chance to stop it the story
seems to be that actually oswald
told may have told other people what he
was going to do may have gotten help in
doing what he was going to do and i
think a lot of the documents we're going
to see are going to suggest just how
much more the cia and the fbi knew about
lee harvey oswald before the
assassination uh let's go to our first
call this is from willie in detroit
michigan you're on with our guest phil
sheenan go ahead
yeah this is really i was coming again
i never heard about the
agreement that jill made with the mop
for as
having his son become president
i mean they had a
monster from new orleans
that
and and their new orleans that's foreign
um that uh
you know if someone was elected you
would have the
the uh uh
the son to
a
backup uh
stop talking about tomorrow but uh you
know
okay willie thanks well without getting
into all the details here i mean there
were a lot of legitimate conspiracy
theories in the kennedy assassination
involving organized crime involving the
mob you know the mob might have had
reason to want to see president kennedy
dead because the kennedy administration
had pursued this war on organized crime
led by attorney general robert kennedy
and
lee harvey oswald indirectly had ties to
organized crime and certainly the man
who killed oswald jack ruby had some
ties to organize crime but i you know
these mob theories are out there i can
understand where they come from i just
haven't seen any credible evidence to to
suggest they're really true let's hear
from john in pennsylvania democrats line
yes uh hello how are you
well uh
i just have a copy of the
dallas morning news
uh and in that in that article
they the the gun experts found the gun
uh that was supposed to be used by
oswald and they named it as a german
mouser
and these guys were gun experts so they
would know the difference between an
italian carcanko and a german mouser
and uh that's why i believe in the in
the conspiracy theory
along with about 75 other 75 percent of
the people in the united states
don't believe that oswald acted alone
and first and how you know when they
find a gun that didn't match
what oswald had then they had to change
the story so obviously something else is
going on here
and you can get a copy of the dallas
morning news i'm sure they still have
copies of that so i'm not making that up
that's here and also
uh dorothy kilgallon was interviewing
uh
jack ruby for many uh for many months
and before she was supposed to see him
for the last time she was found dead in
her apartment
um that's another that's another book
that someone should read too it's by
mark shaw the reporter who knew too much
so if you want to really you know get uh
get your crop that's really a good book
to read
well your caller raises an interesting
point about the rifle and actually this
is useful in explaining where conspiracy
theories come from
after the assassination i think is the
dallas district attorney holds a news
conference where he said that a
german-made mauser rifle had been found
on the sixth floor well it turns out
that the rifle used on the sixth floor
was an italian-made rifle a mandelker
carcano
uh and the the person who i think was
the district attorney who gave the press
conference acknowledged he'd made a
mistake it wasn't a mouser it was a
mandelkirk arcano but because there was
this statement to the press
uh that it was one type of rifle and it
turned out to be another
that's where the conspiracy theories
come from somebody must be covering up
something when in fact that seems to
have been a dumb but honest mistake made
by dallas officials at the time
in houston texas saul go ahead
good morning uh my question is um i know
this has been a huge controversy for a
long time of why they weren't releasing
the documents and all that other fun
stuff but do you think
any of the conspiracy just kind of
questions about the certain shady things
that were actually going on during that
time of the assassination and um just
wanted to ask the question of uh
not to really say do you think all the
conspiracies are real uh do you like
have any example or thinking that it is
actually real some of them and i'll take
my question off the air
well i mean there are a thousand
conspiracy theories so they can't
obviously all be true but
i think
there is at least the possibility
that lee harvey oswald told other people
what he was going to do
and that people offered to help him do
what he was going to do especially to
help him escape if he was ever able to
carry this out i mean that i guess
qualifies as a conspiracy because the
you know the definition of conspiracy is
two people plotting to do wrong and i
guess that would be a conspiracy that is
the one that makes sense to me
and that leads you back to this tale
about mexico city i just don't think
most people are aware that several weeks
before the assassination lee oswalt is
meeting with people who might have
wanted to see president kennedy dead of
all the theories you've heard what's the
most interesting one you've ever heard
about the assassination
you hear lots of interesting theories i
mean everything from
castro did it to space aliens um i think
the one that i find most intriguing
because there's a potential is true is
the idea that other people knew oswald
was going to do this and encouraged him
we saw the warring commission come out
with several volumes of information
concerning what happened what
ultimately did we learn from the
commission's work and was there anything
substantial to the work well i'm a
critic of the commission's work because
it really was a rushed
investigation it was carried out in just
several months the man who led it chief
justice earl warren really didn't want
to do it really wanted it over with in a
hurry and really made several decisions
to protect the legacy of his friend
friend president kennedy that really
hindered the investigation in many ways
for example the public the investigators
on the staff were never allowed to see
president kennedy's autopsy photos or
x-rays because warren was so concerned
that this would uh that they might
become public and damage the legacy of
kennedy because they were so grisly um
but that meant that a lot of the medical
evidence was bungled by the warren
commission uh we'll go next to paul and
paul is in california democrats lying
you're on with our guest phil sheenan
hey good morning pedro thanks for c span
yeah i just wanted to say that uh you
know i i don't think uh oswald did the
assassination uh my reason is that um
when he was when when kennedy was shot
uh he was thrown backward and uh you
know into his wife from uh you know and
anybody who did knows anything about
gunfire uh would say that uh the the
shot could come from the from the grassy
knoll from his from his right
and um you know and the other thing is
it's been proven that oswald could not
have shot all the shots that were fired
that day
and there's a there's some then that's
one thing but the declaring thing is the
cover-up um just how hard the government
made it look like he did do it you know
messed up the autopsy reports um and the
fact that oswald was in russia and he
defected and and said he was going to
disclose all secrets that he knew
about the military and then the
government led him back in the united
states and his wife without any any kind
of debriefing or any kind of penalty
like that that that just wouldn't happen
so i believe oswald did work for the cia
um and he had you know extensive records
by the fbi and so on and so forth so
that's my comment thank you
well there's a lot there but i mean the
idea that oswald wasn't the gunman in
dealey plaza you know i got to say that
all of the most credible scientific
technical study of this over the years
using techniques that weren't available
in the 1960s at the time of the
assassination it shows that oswald was
almost certainly the gunman in dilly
plaza probably the sole gunman
and the i've always found it easy
good to well i i've always thought it a
good idea to frame oswald around another
act which is the murder
shortly after kennedy's assassination of
a dallas police officer by the name of
j.d tippett
many many witnesses see that happen
they're eyewitnesses to the murder of
tidbit by lee harvey oswald why would
oswald have done that if he wasn't
trying to flee because he had just
killed the president
the other question about oswald as not
being able to carry out all the shots at
dealey plaza i would encourage you if
you ever have the chance you're ever in
dallas go to the texas school book
depository it's been turned into a
museum you can actually stand at the
sixth floor window where oswald is said
to have stood you can look out that
window and you can imagine this man a
marine
who had received rifle training
shooting at the president's limousine
with you have to remember the
president's limousine is moving 12 miles
an hour it's moving very slowly i'm not
a i don't know much about guns but i can
tell you the people who do will tell you
that would have been an easy shot for a
man trained in the marine corps and how
to use a rifle we're showing a bit of
there's a predator film where does that
fall so many years later in the place of
understanding what happened to jfk well
it's you know arguably the most
important piece of physical evidence
available to the warren commission in
every investigation ever since because
it really operates as a clock on the
assassination uh because you can line
them up with the with the with you can
show the timing of the various shots and
for the warren commission it was the key
piece of evidence in trying to determine
how oswald could have gotten off all the
shots that hit the president's limousine
uh plano texas democrats line you're on
with our guest go ahead good morning
good morning pedro and thank you for
c-span radio app
first of all i wanted to say that
that was a nice segue that the guests
mentioned the museum the sixth floor
museum i'm very hopeful that a lot of
these documents
do end up at a museum because i think
that's where they belong
but i wanted to ask about mexico city
because
i've heard a few not just you but a few
uh historians and one of the local
historians here mention about mexico
city because i always thought that
the warren commission the photo they
showed of the man that was at mexico
city didn't look anything like oswald
and so i'm really curious to see what
files the fbi has and the cia and i hope
that they will go ahead and release
those because i've always thought that
that visit by oswald was debunked but
maybe i'm wrong
well there are a lot of there are a lot
of allegations that oswald never went to
mexico city that this was an imposter
and a lot of those theories come from
the fact that after the assassination
the cia which closely monitored the
soviet and cuban embassies there with
you know banks of surveillance cameras
could never come up with a photograph of
oswald instead they came up with a
photograph of a
obviously a very different man
and this led to the idea that somebody
was impersonating oswald in mexico city
i'll tell you based on thinking about
this for several years and going through
all the documents that have already been
declassified
there's a lot of reason to believe the
cia covered up what it knew about mexico
city it wanted to cover up just how much
it had known about oswald and his
movements around mexico city because it
would have been such a scandal if it was
shown that the cia had known a lot about
oswald maybe even that he was talking
about killing the president
so i think
the idea that there was an imposter i
can see where those ideas come from
again on the basis of this photograph
that confused so many people but it sure
sounds like oswald was there it sure
sounds like he may have told people that
he was going to kill the president and
that is something that the cia if it
knew about it absolutely wanted to hide
after the assassination is it possible
that the mexican government has
information about the mexico city visit
absolutely and i think one one thing one
reason a lot of these documents have
been held back all these years is
because it's going to expose just how
much sharing there had been been between
the cia and the mexican government
specifically the mexican spy agency i
think there are people in the mexican
government who know an awful lot about
this and have never told that story have
we heard anything about the kennedy
family about the release of these
documents are they okay with that
uh they
actually i was intrigued to see that
congressman kennedy
i guess the grand nephew of president
kennedy has said that the family has
been disappointed that they weren't
consulted about this release
but my understanding is the kennedy
family ultimately wants to see this
material released i see that jacqueline
kennedy the secret service agent who who
protected jacqueline kennedy said
earlier this week that he believed that
mrs kennedy wanted all this material out
on the record let's hear from george and
george is in oklahoma republican line hi
well how you doing this morning thank
you for listening i've just got one
thing to say i've got like a two-part
question though
why
why after 54 years is national security
at risk
that just don't make no sense when
somebody gets on tv and says
we're keeping all this evidence
back because of national security well
who is threatened
who in this country is threatened by
this information
our country our whole country so as we
need national security for that
who has
an interest in this to keep it squashed
so that would be the question i'd ask
people to ask who has an interest in
keeping it squashed
i'm totally with your caller i mean i i
think it's nonsense that this material
is still secret after 54 years you know
i think the argument was made or it may
have been made in the past that there
were people who are identified in these
documents who are alive in 1963 who are
still alive today and they might be in
some sort of danger
if their identities were exposed but i
think it's much more important at this
point for the government to do its best
to show full transparency about the
assassination because it clearly didn't
in the early days is it the
as you understand it is it the national
archives that advises the president on
what to keep and what to release or are
there other people in play i don't think
the national i think the national
archives is just there to release the
material if the president decides to i
think the people advising the president
this week were probably the director of
the cia and the director of the fbi and
i suspect they're making the argument
that some of these documents should not
be released here is albert chicago
illinois independent line
uh yeah hi good morning c-span i just
wanted to
say that anybody who if you just look at
the supruder film up close
you can see that uh before president
kennedy's head snaps back
it bends forward very slightly and as
it's bending forward slightly
his brain matter is coming out towards
the front
and also
no one has ever been able to explain
why
oswald in april tried to assassinate
general edwin walker
and even oswald's own brother who knew
him better than anyone else
looked into his eyes while he was
sitting in the dallas county jail i mean
the dallas city jail and walked away
knowing that oswald did it he acted
alone and he knew why he did he did it
because he wanted notoriety and that's
my comment thank you
well you know i'm glad we returned to
this question of the zapruder film um
because i'll tell you that when i first
saw the zapruder film in in the 1990s it
became public and i remember seeing it
for the first time and it is horrifying
and it's confusing uh it's confusing
because when president kennedy is hit in
the head it looks like indeed it looks
like his head is snapping back and logic
would tell you that if a head is
snapping back it means because a shot is
being fired from the front in this case
it would be coming from this place now
known
in all eternity is the grassy knoll
but i'll tell you that if you talk to
medical experts if you talk to people in
law enforcement they'll say that
actually human bodies do unpredictable
things when hit by a bullet uh you know
a bullet hit causes the nerves to spasm
it causes the shift in fluids in the
body and it looks
illogical that kennedy could have been
hit from a bullet from behind but people
who know the science say that
the fact that his head snapped back does
not does not mean that the
the bullet didn't come from the texas
school book depository from the rear
we're looking at the the soon release of
jfk assassination documents our guests
phil sheenan are with us to talk about
that he's the author of a cruel and
shocking act the secret history of the
kennedy assassination if you want to ask
him questions for the remaining minutes
of this segment 202 748 0001 for
republicans 202 748 000 for democrats
independence 202 748 8 000 to what's
your take on from the on the book
what what's the does this the secret of
it well you know i set out my first book
was about the 911 kitchen and i thought
well it'll be easy to relatively easy to
do my second book about the warren
commission i have some experience here
but it turned out that the warren
assuming the the the warren commission
investigation of kennedy's assassination
the whole debate about the kennedy
assassination is just a morass i mean
there are so many conspiracy theories
and i kept discovering in the course of
my research how much evidence had been
hidden from the warren commission
specifically by the cia and the fbi
which were clearly desperate to hide the
truth about what they had known about
oswald before the assassination and i
kept stumbling on information about this
strange chapter involving mexico city
which i think really may offer some
secret still about what happened
in 1963. republican line johnny and
golden valley arizona
hi um
i was
in the fourth grade
and
[Music]
we
when jfk got shot
and we didn't have counselors grief
counselors back then
we had prayer we prayed in school
and
the principal came in
and told our teacher and our teacher
said
okay everybody gets to go home
the president's been assassinated
but we're going to pray
and we prayed and went home on that day
we had gotten our first color tv a
magnavox stereo
and my dad was hooking it up and the
first thing i saw the tv in color was
blood
blood all over jackie
and if you look at that car
and you slow it down
you will see that the driver turns
around
and shoots
president kennedy in the head
and i lived where they blasted bombs
above the ground
so i've lived in a world all my life
where i've known
people want to kill good
and j.f kelly was good i may have been
10 years old and i didn't know anything
about politics but i know the kennedys
are good people
and there's the only reason
that this information cannot get out
is because it has to do
with oil okay johnny thanks
well you know i think your caller makes
clear just how traumatic this was for
so many americans you know i'm not quite
old enough to remember this but i'll
tell you as i've traveled around the
country talking about the book you know
people
as your caller can as well can remember
exactly where they were they remember
exactly the feelings of
horror and
shock and
fear there was real fear that this might
be the beginning of something much
larger
i i should point out though just in
defense of the driver of president
kennedy's limousine i don't think
there's any evidence that uh the driver
had anything to do with this this is a
shot that came from the rear
uh this is uh phil sheenan and the book
by the way if you want to pick it up for
yourself and check it out a cruel and
shocking act uh see the secret history
of the kennedy assassination and the
author joining us up for this discussion
when it comes to the fascination uh from
the caller previous is it nostalgia that
keeps people fascinated is it still the
sense of unanswered questions in their
mind what do you attribute that to
what's all that i mean this was
you know it's interesting to talk to
people who were
who were alive in 1963 how
you know the other great trauma of our
times was 9 11. for a lot of people the
kennedy assassination was really the
most traumatic national event of their
times and it really did change the way
so many americans feel about their
government you know a lot of americans
apparently the opinion polls continue to
show that most americans don't accept
that the government has ever told them
the truth about the murder of their
president
in kansas republican line ann is next
hello hi go ahead i'm happy to finally
get on i've been listening for a lot of
years but i've never been able to get
through
it's always been busy but i'm ju but
this is i was wanting to comment on the
other one and it was always busy the
other topic but
as far as the kennedy assassination goes
i know that um there's so many different
theories and it affected my life i was
working for a lawyer in beverly hills at
the time it happened and they just were
so i mean they just like oh they got him
i mean they were like
they were like a mafia i mean saying
like the oh the bad guys really got you
know the ones that hated him really did
get through to him and so i was just so
um
you know not knowing what to think about
it you know and just and i just thought
oh it's such a tragedy you know and i
didn't even really care for him as a
president i thought he was
i i didn't but then after that i just
had so much respect after you hear the
story you just realize
we don't all even know what goes on in
our lives i mean it just you think you
know one thing and then you really get
the real story and it's just just like
today everybody's so
against trump for everything but he's a
good person okay and well only because
what keeps us on the topic at half mr
sheenan
well i you know we're going to
talk about president trump and president
kennedy i think one thing that is really
interesting this week is the fact that
that president trump is the man who will
settle this drama for the moment and of
course president trump is himself quite
a conspiracy theory so it's interesting
to think what is going through his mind
as he decides whether or not to resolve
to release these papers that will
resolve some conspiracy theories about
kennedy's death independent line last
calls from john in minnesota
hello can you hear me you're on go ahead
hi i wanted to uh check i heard uh a
question of the possibility that
oswald had been involved in military
intelligence when he was in the marines
he took the uh the magazine the paper
he took a test in russian
he was called comrade
and
as i understand he
was
in a unit that on occasion
when the head person
was sick oswald
was put in that position that he then
was transferred to atsugi
which was a a
in japan
which was an intelligence unit dealing
with you too is any of that true
i think everything you said is true you
know the thing about lee harvey oswald
is that you can understand totally why
there are so many conspiracy theories
about this young man because he lived
his life like a spy you know he
previously tried to defect to the soviet
union he apparently tries to defect to
cuba shortly before the
assassination uh he is a he's he he
speaks russian he reads russian
newspapers you're correct that in the
marine corps they used to refer to him
as comrade and esvoldovich um you know
everything about oswald was suspicious
and you can certainly understand where
people thought that he couldn't have
done this by himself what are you
personally going to do with the
information that comes out do you plan
to revise the book at all or what's your
interest particularly if if if something
really rewrites the story as i
understand that i'd be i'd be intrigued
to try to rewrite some of my book but i
don't think that's going to be the
situation i think we're going to be
presented with lots more evidence to
show that this cover-up by the cia and
the fbi of what they had known before
the assassination i think we're just
going to get new information to bolster
that bill sheenan the author of a cruel
and shocking act thanks for your time
this morning thank you uh 20 minutes
until the end of this program open
phones until 10 o'clock
202-748-8001 for republicans democrats
2027 for eight thousand independence 202
748 8002 we'll take those when we come
back
[Music]